à seulement 2 km de la ligne de front à
vous les dard ces médecins militaires
sont au contact permanent des soldats
dans les tranchées et les blessés ne
cesse d'affluer beaucoup meurent après
d'importantes pertes de sang ce
combattant transportant l'ambulance a pu
être prise en charge à temps vous les
Dar citez minières de l'est de l'Ukraine
au sud de bark mouth et l'une des
dernières cibles des forces russes elles
affirment gagner du terrain
les unités du front Est ont poursuivi
leurs opérations offensives avec succès
elles ont gagné des positions et infligé
une défaite aux Ukrainiens à vous les
dard dans la république populaire de
Donetsk
mais les Ukrainiens affirment au
contraire repousser les forces russes et
défendre leur position dans la région
plus au nord à darkmouth les mois de
combat ont causé de lourdes pertes des
deux côtés ce soldat de 28 ans est une
des dernières victimes de cette guerre
nous devons travailler sans relâche pour
libérer nos terres de ses intrus que
nous n'avons pas invité chez nous
le président ukrainien volo dix
mirzelinski a tout de même reconnu une
situation délicate autour de darkmouth
et vous les Dar situation qui pourrait
encore se détériorer les Russes
multiplient les points d'attaque et
espèrent une victoire après de nombreux
revers sur le terrain